i should be the tired one i've been up
since 4am
why were you up since four just doing
[ __ ] carson's pool
tournament yeah thank you thank you for
inviting all of us by the way carson
yeah but
uh there was only one madman between our
group who was willing to wake up at like
3 30 a.m 3 30 a.m and then i had
japanese school
after so i had to go into tokyo and then
i'd come back here and do the podcast
but
carson [ __ ] you for kicking me out of
the tournament
as you i don't know if you guys probably
didn't see this i was crushing
my opponent would you want to explain
the tournament yeah so it was an eight
ball pool tournament right
and 64 bracket and i was first to play
right so i didn't have any
knowledge of what the this [ __ ] pool
table looked like an 8-bit windows kind
of game it was [ __ ] awful
he kept saying no it's great on the
stream it was [ __ ] awful carson all
right i like your costume by the way
i like you castle but i don't like your
pool table this pool sucked because
anyway immediately i was against uh the
boates and i just started clapping her
dude i was getting all of these balls in
no problem whatsoever
and i was down to the eight ball and
then like something weird happened on
the [ __ ]
and the pool thing right and i'm like
yeah costume what is this he's like
don't worry just click just click so i
just clicked i shouldn't have believed
carson
because of course he's gonna troll me
it's the first game yeah so
i just ignored it potted the black and
i'm like right see you guys in the next
round i was about to
leave the call and they were like wait
you lost connor i'm like what do you
mean i lost
like oh you picked the wrong hole i'm
like it didn't give me oh my god carson
[ __ ] played me though
carson why because in eight ball you
have to select
which pocket you're gonna put the eight
ball yeah and if you put it in a
different hole
i feel so lied to because i'm on mini
clip on the eight ball pool
game right going going way back
but this is it's from mini clip right
the game this game which is the one that
i know he plays all the time you don't
have to select a [ __ ] pocket you just
hit it in any of them
i felt like that's normal
the thing i noticed about playing paul
is like i swear every country i play
paul in with like a different person
everyone has their own [ __ ] rules
yeah i don't i don't know what happens
half the time it's like it's like uno
and monopoly right oh yeah it's like
it's like the free parking spot on
monopoly everyone just makes up their
own [ __ ] rules no one knows what the
actual rule is
it's just no no the actual rules nothing
happens that's just that's
true that's the actual what you would do
is you know how you have to pay the tax
taxes
yeah yeah yeah jail all of that money
goes into the middle and then if you
land on free parking you get the pot
yeah i think that's hopeless optimism
because you know we like we like to
think our taxes go somewhere
perhaps to someone else they don't they
just get sucked into a hole they don't
get
nothing comes of your taxes you're not
happy about it okay
that's what's what happens that makes
that makes more sense yeah nothing
happens
that's just
i don't know how this one rule in
monopoly just got spread around like
globally even though it was like not on
any rule books i think
i like pity rules right yeah yeah i
think because it's so depressing to do a
role in monopoly it's like
wait nothing like nothing like like not
even like a
bad thing yeah no no it's just
especially when it's already a game
where nothing [ __ ] happens sometimes
it's like oh i landed on my own property
could you imagine if there's something
else
a white circle on mario party and it's
like oh my god what's gonna happen
just nothing but nothing nothing's gonna
happen just white okay
have you guys ever completed the game of
monopoly i have never completed a game
yeah
yeah of course i don't know i just don't
have that page i would like i am
so competitive that i will like travel
of course you are i will of course
i will trap everyone in the room until
the game is over like this just
calls for a monopoly right now we need
to play monopoly
how long is a game of monopoly meant to
like last depends how much you suck
because i've been in monopoly games i've
lost like two three hours and i'm just
like look i
don't know that's a short game wait do
you do you okay
do you okay this is the thing right some
people don't do this do you let auctions
happen because
i think in the rules auctions are oh
[ __ ] are they allowed
i thought they were allowed i could be
wrong now i just i just get to a point
in monopoly where just like the money is
just like it's just circular it's just
like
you know that i mean we're like people
are just passing the council which yeah
that's exactly what it feels like
playing game monopoly that i'm using
i like to do the mind games just let my
opponents know immediately from the
get-go i'm out playing them and maybe
they give up maybe it would end faster
if it wasn't for the free parking rule
yeah probably right nothing
like oh [ __ ] i've got 50 bucks left
thank god i landed on free parking
two thousand dollars comes to me and
then it just keeps running yeah
there shouldn't be a way for someone who
has like no properties to get back in
the game yeah yeah yeah
they deserve to be out for their poor
finance so maybe maybe if we do play it
on the podcast or whatever
then we should just completely get rid
of that exactly
do you want to play monopoly with us for
an episode yeah she'll take that yeah
she said she says yeah she said yes
she said absolutely going back to pool
though like what are the rules when you
foul
because i swear there's like a different
[ __ ] rule in every country
when you do a foul like do you get
control of the white ball do you get two
shots
like what what what is the rule
i don't know what the official rules are
but my understanding is if you sink the
white ball then you can place it
wherever you want wherever
you can but it is is it wherever you
want past like a certain line
no is it wherever you want what i
thought it was but apparently it's not
isn't that snook yeah that's a different
game [ __ ] dude i want to say anything
because i'm going to be wrong
yeah yeah we're probably we're probably
wrong here and there's going to be
someone in the comments that's like
uh i don't know the international rules
of paul you are all wrong
if you pot two in a row multiball
happens right where there's
no i think like yeah because every
single person i've gone to baggage with
to play paul yeah they're just like oh
it's two shots right
it's like no no no no it's behind this
like white line yeah you have to shoot a
four no you can place it anywhere
it's different every single time it's
like whatever people just make up their
own rules there's always house rules and
i don't know america's america works in
his own system asia works on another
system and europe works on their own
system
i don't [ __ ] know i just go with the
flow most of the time because recently i
found out with uno
right do you stack the plus two cards
yeah that's a rule
no it's not that's not a rule the
official rule is you can't stack that's
so [ __ ] boring
i know that's so long like i looked it
up because there's so many people who
are like no you can't stack plus two or
you can stack plus dude
everybody thought yes of course you can
stack plus two that makes the game so
much more interesting
i looked up the official rules you can't
stack plus twos
but that's not fun exactly and also joey
[ __ ] i remember this pissed me off
dude there's like a 30 minute game of
uno i just wanted it to end right
and what i normally do in uno is that i
will save the all
color cards until the end so that i can
just win when i get booner yeah yeah
yeah yeah and joey was like uh no no you
can't do that
you can't put down it has to be a solid
card it is it that is an official role
on the uno game on the pc you can do
that
explain that joey yeah pc is not canon
dude
we were also very drunk then yeah we
were also we were also
shouting out like a different standard
for the different colors i i was just
like asleep by the end of it and joey
was the only one who wanted to drag on
this suffering
it was like like 2 a.m or something we
were all like heavily drunk i was like
struggling to keep my eyes
asleep and when you like ended the game
i was secretly like
yes yes it's i'm finally over there joey
goes um
excuse me that is not a rule you cannot
end the game
look if i'm gonna if you're gonna put me
through a 30-minute [ __ ] uno game
i want to win i want to win on the
proper rules
who gives a [ __ ] man it's not it's not
even a skill based game no no it's not
it's not
i just had fun just every time there was
a red card just being like
it's like every single time
the people in the other room must have
thought what the [ __ ] is happening in
there they're just screaming magicians
every
two seconds every time we drop the green
card